problema número 1 la agenda de un
proyecto en un solo año fiscal tiene un
presupuesto de 12 mil 600 dólares
dividido entre 12 lugares mensuales
iguales al final del cuarto mes del año
fiscal la cantidad total gastada en el
proyecto es de cuatro mil quinientos
ochenta dólares en qué cantidad ha
superado el presupuesto el proyecto
bueno aquí lo que tenemos que hacer es
dividir esta cantidad original del
proyecto en un año estos doce mil
seiscientos dólares entre los doce meses
esto es igual a 1050 dólares por mes por
mes y nos dicen que para el cuarto mes
el proyecto lleva gastado cuatro mil
quinientos ochenta son cuatro mil
quinientos ochenta dólares después
después
cuatro meses
veamos cuando deben de haber gastado de
acuerdo al presupuesto inicial para
estos cuatro meses así que esta cantidad
la multiplicamos por 4 4 por 0 04 por 5
20 llevamos 24 por 0 0 llevamos 2 aquí
lo ponemos 4 por 14
cuatro mil doscientos dólares es lo que
deberían de llevar cuatro mil doscientos
dólares de acuerdo al presupuesto pero
se han pasado vamos a ver cuál es la
diferencia entre estas dos cantidades
4.580 menos cuatro mil doscientos va a
ser igual a 380 dólares
es la opción
veamos el siguiente problema
para cuál de los siguientes valores de n
en 100 cn entre n el resultado no es un
entero vamos a simplificar esto tenemos
+ n / n que esto es igual a 100 entrene
más n / l esto es 1 así que esto es
igual a 100 / n
+ 1 para que esto no sea un entero esta
parte de acá debe tener una fracción
debemos elegir una n tal que esta
división no sea exacta la opción nada
nos dice que es 1 100 ante 1 si es una
división exacta así que no es la opción
la opción b nos dice que es 2
y 100 es divisible entre 1250 así que
tampoco es la opción b la opción c es 3
siguen dividido entre 3 no nos va a dar
una visión exacta va a ser una fracción
así que esta opción la se
es la correcta muy bien veamos el
siguiente
tercer problema tenemos estos dos
rectángulos y nos dicen que ambos tienen
la misma área nos preguntan cuál es la
altura del rectángulo y bueno sabemos
que el área que es base por altura del
rectángulo y 9 por l va a ser igual al
área del rectángulo x que es 18 por 12
18 por 12 esto es igual a vamos a hacer
lo que en un lado 18 por 12 8 por 2 16
llevo una 2 por 12 con la comuna que
llevo son 318 por una es 18 el resultado
de 6 12 216 216 9 por l es igual a 216
entre 9 ambos lados de esta igualdad y
nos va a quedar que él es igual vamos a
ver 216 entre 9 cuánto es aquí 9 por 2
18 21 menos 18 son 3 bajamos el 6 9 por
4 36 36 menos 36 es igual a cero así que
el resultado de la dirección es 24 el
lado min 24 está l es igual a 24
veamos el siguiente problema el número 4
nos dice que un contenedor tiene seis
cartones cada cartón tiene cajas y cada
caja tiene 100 clips cuántos clips habrá
en dos contenedores bueno
nos dicen que un contenedor contenedor
voy a abreviar lo así
es igual a ce cartones de cartones
nos dicen que un cartón
carlton es igual a b cajas
y que una caja escribir bien esto una
caja
tiene 100 clips
por lo tanto dos contenedores
van a ser igual a dos por cada cartón
tiene b cajas así que esto va a ser por
be y cada caja tiene 100 clips por 100
clips
esto es igual a 100 porsche por b por 2
es igual a 200 de borbén que es nuestra
opción
muy bien pasamos al quinto problema este
nos dice la suma de no menos primos que
son mayores a 60 pero menores a 70 y es
vamos a ver cuáles son los números
primos en este rango 60 no es número
primo 61-61 este si es número primo 62
no es primo 63 es divisible entre tres
así que tampoco lo es
64 tampoco es primo 65 tampoco 66 no 67
creo que este sí es primo
68 no es primo 69 tampoco así que
sin creo que sí estos son los dos únicos
números primos que hay en este rango por
lo que es 61 más 67 es igual 7 más 186
más 6 12 128 que es nuestra opción de
siguiente problema una tormenta de
lluvia aumenta el nivel de agua
almacenada en las reservas del estado de
124 mil millones de litros a 138 mil
millones de litros si la tormenta de
lluvia aumentó las reservas a un 82 por
ciento de su capacidad total
aproximadamente cuantos miles de
millones de litros les faltaban las
reservas de su capacidad total antes de
la tormenta ok
nos dicen que debe tener 124 mil
millones pasaron a 138 mil millones
y aparte nos dicen que esto es el 82%
de capacidad
capacidad o lo que es lo mismo 0.82 se
va a ser la capacidad total
y esto es igual a 138 es lo que estoy
expresando todo esto de aquí los
expresando así y como nos piden los
litros que faltan para llenar la
cantidad total antes de la tormenta pues
va a ser esta cantidad menos la cantidad
de litros que tenía antes de la tormenta
vamos a ver vamos a esta es la cantidad
total la capacidad total podemos saber
cuál es la capacidad total vamos a abrir
todo esto en 3.82 0.82 y aquí también
entre 0.82 entonces mi capacidad total
de cada contenedor es igual a 138 38 /
0.82
y esa capacidad total le tengo que
restar los miles de millones de litros
que tenía antes de la lluvia de la
tormenta así que va a ser
138 / 0.82 menos los 124 que había antes
ok vamos a hacer esta operación 138 en
3.82
138 en 3.82 como no quiero trabajar con
los puntos decimales ahorita voy a
agregar aquí dos ceros y este punto 82
se va a volver 82 muy bien ok si yo
multiplico 82 por 1 pues va a quedar
aquí 82
138 menos 82 es igual
65 560 multiplicador a 682 por 6 y nos
quedan 6 por 2 12 6 por 8 48 149 esto
esto y me queda
68 bajamos el otro 0 y ahora
multiplicamos por 88 por 2 16 8 por 8 64
165 restamos y nos quedan
424 ok no es una división exacta pero
bueno vamos a trabajar con esta cantidad
más o menos aproximada así que la
capacidad total aproximada la capacidad
total de cada contenedor es de 168 mil
millones de litros a esto le restó los
124 que tenían anteriormente 168 menos
124 y nos quedan 44 44 mil millones de
litros son los que faltaban en las
reservas antes de la tormenta y esta es
nuestra opción